it's very important to keep yourself
well hydrated with good quality water
good quality water has got to be it's
got to be fluoride free water fluoride
is neurotoxic there's really really
strong science supporting that fluoride
hurts the brain especially of children
there's there's studies that have come
out in recent years that show that
there's a very strong correlation
between the level of fluoride and the
water that children are drinking and
that then the child's IQ the higher the
level of fluoride in the water the lower
the IQ so fluoride is neurotoxic and
fluoride also inhibits enzymes enzymes
are the catalysts in our biology for
energy production and most of our
biochemical reactions so this is really
important this is not just the nice
thing to do because I'm mentioning this
this is fundamentally important that
you're drinking water that is not
contaminated with fluoride yes the
fluoride that's that's in the water is
added to the water supposedly to reduce
tooth decay despite the propaganda about
that there is actually very little
science supporting that there's any
value in drinking fluoridated water for
reducing tooth decay but there's a lot
of science supporting that fluoride is
neurotoxic it hurts the thyroid gland
you're hurting your thyroid gland the
thyroid gland is the master gland of
your metabolism the thyroid gland which
is right here produces hormones that
regulate the rate of your metabolism
your metabolism is all about how
efficiently or it efficiently you're
producing energy so fluoride for flight
hurts the brain it will hurt your energy
it it's it's an obstacle to good health
so be very attentive to the quality of
water that you can
assuming and consume enough water for
instance I have a little box here which
you may recognize even after distance
it's nothing more or less than the box
that the toothpaste go again
toothpaste comes in and it's fluoridated
[Applause]
did you know that every toothless no
matter just Colby any toothpaste that
has fluoride in it has the following
warning printed on the box as well as on
the tube did you know there was a
warning on those tubes a lot of people
didn't I'm glad that this group is a
little better educated and let me just
quick read you it's in tiny tiny print
so I just printed itself out for myself
so I could read it easily
it says warnings keep out of the reach
of children under 6 years of age don't
you want to teach your kids to brush
their teeth keep out of it
you can't give them toothpaste but
you're told that they need the fluoride
so that they got healthy teeth and no
cavities aren't you well listen to this
if more than is used for brushing is
accidentally swallowed man you kids
don't have the capability yet of
spitting out this toothpaste if it's
accident but they flavor it like candy
they make it look like candy if it's
accidentally swallowed get medical help
or contact a poison control center right
away did you know there was poison they
market they tell you so most people
don't leave this a couple of years ago I
had the same box and I had an audience
of larger group than this even of 1200
people
and I asked for so of hands who read it
and who kept it out of reach of children
not one single hand went up people don't
believe that there's poison and
something that they put in their mouth
never mind six-year-olds how about you
do you think it's good for you to put
poison in your mouth even if you split
it out the mouth and the mucous membrane
in the mouth is highly absorptive and
you get this poison furthermore dentists
who are knowledgeable and honest will
tell you that there is no proof that
fluoride does anything to prevent
cavities
on the contrary there are two cities for
instance Toronto and Vancouver in Canada
Toronto has long been fluoridated
Vancouver is not Vancouver's healthier
children with less cavities and
healthier adults and healthier elderly
people without the broken bones because
they get brittle and they cause damage
hey this isn't all children - - for use
only a pea-sized amount and supervise
the child's brushing and rinsing to
minimize swallowing they tell you don't
swallow don't let your kids swallow it
it's poison and if they do control the
pannier in contact the poison control
center but they fluoridate you water
more than 52 percent of American states
and cities have now fluoridated water
why it doesn't do a thing to help your
teeth or your children's teeth it is one
of the most powerful poisons there are
it's highly toxic it causes bones to be
brittle teeth to get blackened
and it damages your immune system the
very system that you need to keep your
healthy and to help to fight infections
and cancer it's not just cancer and now
comes something else interesting there
was a professor of dentistry at Harvard
University worldwide recognized
University Harvard who had an assistant
who happened to be studying for a PhD
and this assistant was working on
fluoridation and found a very heavy
contact between boys especially from
Harvard who were gathering fluoridated
water for several years also in their
home states hometowns and a very nasty
form of cancer called osteosarcoma it's
a bone cancer it's painful and there's
no cure and chemo only worsens and chemo
makes money for them and she presented
this to the professor by the name of
Douglas in case you run across it I
don't keep the secret and what did he do
with this tremendously important
information that boys were getting sick
and dying from the fluoridated water
what did he do he hid it in a drawer
where deep down under his desk nobody
ever heard about it as long as this
woman was his assistant
studying for her PhD but then she got
her de PhD stopped her connection made
herself
private she became a prime in private
practice and she published this material
that she found now here stands Harvard
with egg in their faces
their professor was hiding the fact that
what he was promoting fluoride was
killing young men miserably in pain and
misery and then comes the upshot
professor Douglas it turned out was paid
by Colgate to promote fluoridation and
just so that you know he showed that he
really meant well
he gave a million dollars for a new
dental building at Harvard now what
professor do you know gets enough pay to
donate a million dollars Colgate donated
okay so be careful and I have another
little bit of the advice if you're not
going to read these warnings best of all
don't ever buy anything or eat anything
or feed your children anything I'll give
them anything that has to have printed
material on it that says what's in it
and God forbid if there is something on
that in that material any words that you
don't understand or anything that you're
not quite sure the good Lord put on the
earth for us to eat don't touch don't
touch